Hey,
what's going on is bill barn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
October 14th,
2013.
How's it going?
How are you?
Is Everything okay in your neck of the woods?
Um,
I know what you think of right off the bat.
Jesus belt.
This podcast is even later than it usually is.
Well,
I will,
I would counter.
Okay.
I would counter that verbal assault by saying,
well didn't you have the fucking day off today?
We'll dead Ya.
Well great because I did too.
I don't know why.
Oh,
it's Columbus Day,
right?
Columbus Day.
It's Columbus Day.
He came over here,
there was already people he cut off the fucking hands cause they couldn't find
gold and we celebrate him cause he was kind of white even though I think he was
from Spain.
And if he came to Boston and try to get a job,
he'd be really fucked with most of the people he'd the interview with.
Um,
what's,
um,
so yeah,
today it's Columbus Day.
Christopher Christopher Columbus.
Sorry,
I went to the Brood,
say had a couple of beers,
their rights to deal with me.
Christopher fucking cake.
Chrissy,
get on the fucking ball and do the job we paid you for Christopher Columbus.
Alright.
Discovered America Fall you volume of people who have never picked up a history
book.
He sailed in the 1492 he sailed the ocean blue.
He thought he was going to the West indies.
This is like there once was a man from Nantucket there once was a man from Spain
who had in his balls a pain.
He couldn't get laid.
He tried every day.
So he said,
fuck it,
I'm going to sail.
So I have something to talk about.
I Dunno guys.
This is funny to me and I'm buzzing pretty fucking good.
And then I really don't give a shit.
I don't give a shit.
I care.
I care about you.
And how did you enjoy Columbus state?
Or did you do,
did you put on like a fucking George Washington wig and stand on the neck of the
tennis person that you know in celebration of all the great things he did?
Um,
I've always had difficulty once I got past a certain age with the fact that that
guy,
they said,
he discovered,
he discovered it for Europe.
He didn't discover it.
There was already people here.
You know what I mean?
Just sitting here,
living off the land,
you know,
little mud flap over their junk using up every bit of the animal.
They did nothing wrong.
That's the overcorrection of native Americans where they've now become like
these godlike people where none of them were bad.
You know,
none of them would have fucked you out of your four zero one k money had they
understood what a 401k was and could tie a tie.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
people are people.
Let's,
let's,
let's get down to brass tacks here.
People.
All right.
Just cause you just sitting there,
floss in with the fucking bison tendon doesn't mean that,
you know,
if you had a car,
you wouldn't get a little grabby on the first date.
All right?
Okay.
And if you can't do the math on that,
that I can't help you.
Um,
yeah,
it's Christopher Columbus Day.
Mary go vis speechy remember,
I'll let that fucking awful history stuff.
He's sitting there with half a fucking erection looking at some chick next to
you and there's some guy in a god damn tweed coat talking about a Vinny del
Negro.
What was the other,
what was it?
What was the other guy?
The other world explore.
It was a merry go Vespucci it was Christopher Columbus and then there was a guy
who had like a Vinny del Negro name but it wasn't Vinny del Negro.
But then that's in my head so I'll never be able to think of what the fuck was
it?
Was it Marcus the Laffeyett?
Was that him?
He wasn't the trader in the revolutionary war.
That was benedict Arnold Barkus the left yet.
Did he start Marquette University?
He did something.
He wasn't with Lewis and Clark.
I don't fucking know.
You know it's funny.
It's just all the shit that was done to create this country and they kind of
boil it down to like 14 people.
These guys sailed up a river.
This guy found it.
This guy said,
I can't tell a lie.
And a the other guy said,
hey,
why don't you lay off the black people for a minute?
You know,
and that's pretty much the first 200 years of history in this country as far as
I can tell,
you know,
and for all you Europeans listening and all you Australians,
that doesn't mean your country's better.
Alright,
so fuck you and your fish and chips and your vegemite sandwiches because nobody
gives a shit.
All right.
You just as filthy as we are,
which brings me to a wonderful fucking conversation that I had with Paul Versey.
Paul Versey,
right?
So neither one of us has watched baseball in a while.
I stopped in 2010 when a poppy tested for some substance and they never said
what it was.
And at that point,
pretty much everybody from the old four series,
like five guys on both teams had tested positive or whatever.
So it was kind of fair.
I guess I wrote it up,
guys beat,
you're write it up guys.
But it was just getting annoying.
And I might say poppy was doing any shit,
but that was just one of those things where I was like,
listen,
I've watched enough fucking train wrecks.
I don't want to watch this one either.
Get it out of the game or do what you know you've got to do with the long haul,
which is you got to make the shit legal.
All right.
I love how a football player who is running around tackling people at the NFL
level,
which is basically like getting into a fucking car accident.
You know,
not a major one,
but a pretty significant one.
You got to exchange insurance cards like every other fucking play.
He can't do roids but a fucking,
some singer can't get onstage Bayer like la about,
I'll do better.
Nobody do you warp wall.
They can't fucking do that.
Then it's okay for them to give rides to get some roids right.
And they're all fucking voicebox look up at the ceiling.
They're fucking,
uh,
Vladimir,
whatever the fuck your name is.
Fatty with the beard.
What does that guy's name?
He was the guy who was part of the three tenors.
You know,
they look like Franco Harris.
If he was white,
the fuck is that guy's name.
And he was bald.
Jesus Christ.
It's like the,
anybody knows like y'all,
everybody knows one opera singer and this is the guy,
right?
Whatever that fucking guy,
I don't even know how I got onto that shit.
The fuck was I talking?
I'm talking about virgin.
All right.
So me and [inaudible] have not watched.
Oh,
so much steroids before I was talking about Versie steroids.
Yeah.
They're fucking synergetic shit that you watch late at night where they show
some old guy with his gut hanging out,
right?
He's got a tattoo of Rosie the riveter right above where his fucking spleen used
to be and he's just done.
He's got creases in his torso that it doesn't even make sense.
It's not even like fat creases.
It means like organs have been removed and there's a space there now they can
only be filled up with the flesh on the outside of your torso.
What are those kinds of creases?
Okay.
And then by the end of the commercial,
that guy standing there looking like fucking Gronk Koski
and he's hanging out with some fucking 35 year old chick who wasn't raised
right.
Clearly you're dead.
Took off.
So now she has the big strong father figure that she always wanted.
And I'm sitting there go,
well Jesus Christ,
I thought P90x was impressive.
That was getting people in their twenties,
thirties and forties and shape.
What the fuck is this shit?
And I went up,
I went on the Internet,
the old inner web as they call it on my favorite fucking show on TV,
fast and loud.
Uh,
but went on the Inter web and uh,
I looked it up to see what the shit was.
And it's,
uh,
it's,
it's HGH,
that's what they're doing.
And they said they're going like with our system as far as my research goes,
before I get in trouble here,
as far as my research,
according to my research,
which was basically I looked up synergetics scam question mark.
And the first thing came up was what they were given these people,
human growth hormone,
well,
obviously human growth homework.
And then you give him a fucking handful of Viagara.
They go out and they hit the clubs,
right?
Go over to the fucking jukebox.
They put on a little fucking Glenn Miller,
Glenn Miller,
little moonlight serenade.
And next thing you know,
some fucking broad from this generation with their glow sticks in too many
tattoos in a giant fucking ear lobes that you could stick a pool cue through.
All right?
Next thing you know,
she's dropped to her fucking dubstep knees and she's blowing a veteran of the
Korean War.
That's how it goes down,
okay?
And that right there people is the upside of steroids.
You know,
look at all these fucking ways when you're watching the real housewives,
those aren't real housewives.
Those are a higher breed of housewife,
okay?
I'm just loving all the women right now,
just so high.
Why God?
How could you say that?
I'll tell you why.
Because this is the deal.
They still had,
they had children,
and this still,
despite the limits of modern day science,
is this still trying to look like a hot piece of ass?
Now?
They're not doing it,
but I'm telling you right now,
just like that guy that you love that goes into the quarter,
right?
That guy,
that little fucking returned punts,
the fucking wedge breaker.
The guy who's all fucking hard.
That's the female version of the wedge.
Baker breaker right there.
It's those thoughts on the fucking real housewives.
Look at fuckable India 50s.
God bless you.
Making people do double takes.
Like is that 20?
Oh wait a minute now.
No,
she's 55 gross.
But there is that moment.
You know what I mean?
You got to give it up to them.
I don't even know what I'm talking about.
I'm a couple of log is in.
I went to the Bruins game today.
I had no fucking intentions of going wait,
stay on.
Stay on target.
I'll get to the Bruins game and a fucking second.
Um,
so forsee last night,
you know,
I'm the biggest,
you couldn't be more of a band wagon red sox fan this year unless you started
after game three of the Tampa Bay series.
The first two games,
red sox games I watched this year was game one and game two of the Tampa Bay,
uh,
playoffs.
And then I missed the rest of the series.
I travel,
you know what I mean?
I am into Lego collectibles.
I have a schedule.
Um,
is there such a thing anyways,
and I've watched the,
uh,
the first two games of this tiger city city,
this tiger series.
And it is an instant fucking classic.
If you guys are like me and you went away from the game for a couple of years,
uh,
this is a great one.
Great one to come back to.
The first one was an absolute gem one,
nothing game.
It was one of those deals with the Tigers won one.
Nothing.
And I felt like we lost like eight nothing.
I mean they would just fucking Mona's doubt.
All right.
Huge loss.
And now they got the fucking upper here to the city center or the series.
Why don't keep saying city?
I don't know.
Probably cause you were drinking bud hide.
I'm
not like there.
They automatically have the upper hand in the,
in the series right now we have to win game two.
Look what the fuck they did.
So then they got this other cycle.
I don't know anybody's names then I got other than Cabrera cause he wanted the
triple crown.
And I got to tell you something to right now,
the athletic gifts that that man was given,
that he could be in the fucking horrific shape that he's in,
instill with the triple crown.
He is in Joe Derosa shape.
Okay.
When I look at Joe to Rosa,
when I bite into a York peppermint patty,
when I look at Joe de Rosa,
I look at a man,
okay,
who has never done a pushup in his life other than after he's been drunk.
And He fell down and did a face plant.
And even then it's a girl push up right with his fucking quarter roid knees in
the grass.
And if he's on a fucking hill that favors him.
If he's facing up the hill,
he can actually get his horrific fucking,
uh,
example of a torso up off of that grass.
Why am I trashing Joe?
He's not here to defend himself.
Oh,
Jesus.
Joe,
does somebody fucking send this to you because they're miserable.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
That Cabrera Guy.
Jesus.
What a fucking awful,
horrible.
He looks like he should be selling like concessions and he's eaten.
Have to,
he's just got a puffy face.
He's got a flabby neck and it's like he's not fat.
He's not in shape.
He's just sort of fuck it.
Know he runs around.
Well,
what?
He's done easy like a fucking ball at mid chocolate ship.
Gee,
you know what?
It reminds you of like Warren Sapp whenever I used to watch Warren Sapp play,
I've just used to remember like what would happen if this guy actually fucking
worked out?
What have you actually worked out?
Okay.
Warren Sapp was in worse shape than most of the people in the stands that were
watching him.
Just,
you know,
to look at them.
I used to always stick ice stuff.
I thought I was like towards the end of his career,
one of these years,
he's going to say fuck it and he's going to come in with a flat stomach and he's
going to reach like Reggie white level defense event.
And he never did.
He never did it.
So anyway,
so [inaudible] I texted him,
I'm in Boston,
right?
And I'm watching the fucking red sox game and he puts them on and you have to
understand red sox Yankees hatred is,
Paul has even watched the game and I don't know a couple of years right this
second.
I don't think he was watching the game for more than three seconds.
And he just starts sending me tweet after fucking tweet about how awful the
fucking red sox beards are.
Okay.
He just,
he was beside himself.
He thought it was a disgrace to the game.
The reality is,
is he just,
he hates the fucking reds.
I mean,
I don't like their beards either,
but like,
let's see here,
let me read some of this shit.
Uh,
okay.
Where the
fuck is it?
Ah,
Shit.
Oh,
load earlier messages do.
We were texting so much during the game.
I had to go all the way.
Okay,
you don't have the success to take the slot.
What the fuck is this?
Where the hell is it?
Let me get to the top up here.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm the worst.
Oh,
this is me talking about Paul and the mob.
You get whacked for running your mouth with a fucking [inaudible].
Is it even going to be worth it at this point?
Jesus Christ.
Bill load earlier messages.
Here we go.
All right.
Where the fuck am I?
Okay,
this is what verse he writes.
He says,
I just turned it on because I said,
Papi,
Grand Slam tie game.
Oh by the way,
I'll like not a bunch of tiger fans but about a half dozen of,
we're just trashing me.
I'm just saying the series over better,
better luck next year.
Red Sox when they were up five,
nothing in game too about you know,
seven innings in and all I just kept thinking in my head is like,
dude,
have you ever watched a baseball game before?
It's like they were running out of time.
As long as there's no outs,
it's,
it goes on forever.
It's like that George Carlin bit this plenty of fucking time.
So anyways,
long story short,
they fucking load them up and poppy hits a Grand Slam to tie the game.
So I write poppy Grand Slam Tie game for as he writes.
I just turned it on exclamation point and I was thinking like,
wow,
he's going to be like,
all right,
awesome game immediately.
His first sentence,
do the socks.
Beards are so fucking stupid.
They,
the whole anti Yankee facial hair is so douchey.
They look ridiculous.
Grow up babies,
lol.
Um,
and then we just start going back and forth.
He said,
you guys look like Lumber Jack Morons,
your baseball players,
the worst and a,
I just keep going like,
oh,
you know,
where did Derek Jeter watch the game tonight?
It of course he's like,
uh,
on fucking Miss Universe is pussy.
I'm like,
isn't he like 38 at this point?
It's starting to get creepy,
isn't it?
He really is like some zillionaire guys still going to fucking Hooters.
That's just jealousy on my part anyway,
so we just start fucking giving each other shit.
The fuck was my point to this dude.
Half your team looks like they're in a fucking Halloween Halloween costume.
It's embarrassing.
And then I wrote back,
not as embarrassing is missing the playoffs.
Uh,
what would you do if a comedy club had a no facial hair policy?
He writes back to shave,
but we don't look like assholes.
I'd be working still working.
Stand up.
I don't know what the fuck this,
I can't get it to this cause I started saying what comedians would actually be,
would play for the Yankees versus the one for the red sox.
Just to give you a hint,
the red sox had Sam Kinison and all the bad ass ones.
And uh,
the Achy said all the fucking clean cut.
I Dunno.
You know the deal.
I don't know.
I know the podcasts just went off the fucking risk.
Give me a break.
Okay.
I've worked with a head of steam.
Okay,
what are you gonna do it?
But I gotta tell you something.
That whole Yankee fucking thing about no facial hair.
I'm old enough to remember in the 70s when they all looked like they were going
to go shoot a fucking porno and then out of nowhere they started taking on this
can holier than thou like Notre Dame Horse Shit ghetto.
We weren't clean shaven.
Where are we first?
He's going.
Yeah,
they look like gentlemen.
It's like Paul.
There were a bunch of roid up cuts just like everybody else just because they
look like they're going to deliver a fucking newspaper to you.
All of a sudden.
That makes a better give me a fucking break.
I liked it.
The red sox looked like the mood dogs,
you know,
for you old fucking wrestling fans.
I don't give a shit just as long as,
as long as they would.
It's got to be a great series.
I think it's called seven and I'm actually a big fan of a,
the tigers and that type of stuff.
I had family that grew up in Michigan,
so,
uh,
I like the Tacos.
I got no,
I got no beef with those guys.
But what the fuck was I going to bring up here?
Um,
is it time to read a fucking yeah,
it is.
Certainly do a little,
uh,
yeah.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Where the fuck is it?
Okay,
here we go.
Here we go.
A dollar shave club.
Everybody,
you know,
there's so many things in this world that irritate me.
Uh,
Paul versus a misguided anger about the red sox beards when he should just
really say,
I'm really sad that my team isn't in the playoffs and you guys have a really
good shot at winning the world series.
But instead he turns into like Joan Rivers,
like he's on the red carpet,
you know,
Dustin Pedroia,
what are you wearing?
Um,
what Shelby thinks can irritate you wide at why ed razors to the list.
It's time to stop milking your razor blade.
Come on.
We've all done it.
You know the Dale,
you know what the brand name razors,
they're like a zillion dollars.
You pay outrageous prices.
So you sit there and you try to squeeze the life out of these razors until they
start feeling like a rusty soda can drag it across your face.
All right,
well guess what?
It's time to move on.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing quality blades,
right to your God damn door for just a few bucks a month.
My listeners have been taking advantage of this ad like no other ad,
and I have not gotten one complaint,
but now that I've said that,
I will get my first complaint,
but I will guarantee you there will be no more.
This dish out of all of them has been an absolute home run.
All right?
You'd never have to think about getting razor blades again.
They send a pack every month so you can change.
Change your blades once a week.
I love these guys and you've got to love them too.
Uh,
they've also has a new product called the one wipe jolly.
it's a buttwipe for men and it's classy.
Check out the video for that and sign up for your razors today.
Go to the dollar shave club.com forward slash bar,
that's dollar shave club.com,
forward slash bar or go to billboard.com and click the dollar shave club banner
today and is always Hulu plus everybody.
This is a whole new way to watch television.
All right.
Where you,
you,
you my friend?
Are they ahead of the network?
You decide when and where and what.
All right,
well here's the deal.
You've probably tried hulu.com well,
now it's time to try Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Hulu plus lets you watch thousands of hit TV shows that a selection of a movies
on your television or on the go with your smartphone or tablet and it all
streams in HD for the best viewing experience.
She can't beat this with Hulu.
Plus you could watch your favorite current TV shows like Saturday night live
community,
family guy,
South Park,
breaking bad,
whatever the hell you want to watch.
You can also check out exclusive content including Hulu originals.
They have original series like the awesomes starring Snl,
Seth Meyers and mood boy starring Chris O'Dowd from bride's maid.
A Hulu plus also offers a great selection of a claim films for only 799 a month.
You can stream as many TV shows and movies as you want,
whenever you want.
You're out of your mind.
If you don't do this right now,
you can try Hulu plus for free for two weeks.
When you go to Hulu plus.com/bill that's a special offer offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use Hulu plus dot cubs slash bill so you get the extended free
trial and they know that we sent you.
Go to Hulu plus.com/bill now or click the Hulu plus banner of the podcast page
at [inaudible] dot com um,
all right,
back to the podcast here.
Oh,
you know what's fucking hilarious to me?
I got to do a Paul Versey here and say,
dude,
I called it because I did call it.
All right.
Where the hell's my fucking God damn
well I'm the worst.
I am the absolute worst there it is.
Weeks ago when I first started making fun of Seattle,
the Seattle Seahawks going for the loudest record.
Just to give you a recap,
I basically said,
well,
hey,
when you haven't won a championship,
you have to hang your hat on something and if you get this record,
are you going to start singing?
We A,
they're loud is my friends and we'll keep on loses screaming until we lose that
bullshit.
And I said,
you can go back.
It's documented on my podcast.
I said that Seattle Seahawks fans,
we're not that loud that it was the building.
I'm not saying that they're not good fence,
but then not as fucking loud as everyone's making them out to be.
You go to the game and it's so fucking loud.
You look around and you're looking at people while they're chairing and you're
like,
that face does not add up to this loud or they piping noise in and it turns out
there,
I'll know had built a stadium specifically designed to contain the noise.
So it's like a crowd on fucking HGH there,
a bunch of cheap,
they're the Jason Gmbs of crowds.
And from day fucking one when broke their balls about it.
I said,
I went to a Kansas City chiefs game and those fuckers were louder than the ones
in Seattle.
And they,
this weekend broke the record for the loudest crowd,
which is the dumbest fucking record ever.
Um,
the loudest crowd.
And they did it in a stadium that was built when we still thought the Vietnam
War was winnable.
All right?
So it's not even like they just beat Seattle.
They destroyed them.
Okay.
So now I have a new song for the Seattle Seahawks fans out of respect for them
and their one week of holding the title,
they held the title for one week.
Kind of like when the heavyweight champion gets arrested or refuses to go to war
and they just strip him of his title and they give it to some fucking
[inaudible] and he has it for one week until he gets knocked out.
That's what happened to them.
So here's the new song.
All right?
We were not allowed is for one we do
do.
And then a bunch of
Kansas City booboo,
booboo screen.
Oh,
louder.
And you know,
it's funny,
I don't have a fucking salt for it.
You know it's fucking hilarious.
Is Kansas City at least it's won a super bowl.
Everybody,
when did they do it?
Come on.
They were still in the AFL,
booboo,
booboo pool,
super bowl for Leonie Dawson.
63 talks,
power trap,
whatever the fuck it was extra.
But that rolled up thing and the fucking hairpiece walking up and down chewing
his gum.
That was where the Vikings,
the original buffalo bills lost their first of soon to be four Superbowls.
Uh,
inexplicably.
They had Fran Tarkenton,
they had the purple people eaters.
They had Paul Krauss,
they had fucking chuck foreman.
They had Freddy Cox kicking the God Damn Ball and nothing happened.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
I mentioned earlier that,
um,
so Seattle just breaking your fucking balls.
All right?
So,
you know,
don't cry in the rain in blow your fucking brains out like that guy did.
Okay.
And then is stripper wife read his fucking suicide note to every anyone who
would want to listen,
which was arguably
the greatest example of stealing someone else's thunder I've ever seen.
You know,
how do you blow your own head off and not get top billing?
It's just fucking insane.
I'll tell you how somebody comes in and read a suicide note and is emoting about
how devastated they are.
You know,
it's like,
it wasn't your day lady.
All right.
It was what's left of that guy up there in the fucking attic.
Uh,
all right.
That seemed really insensitive,
but I am a fan of all of the people mentioned,
listen,
sometimes I hurt feelings on this podcast,
but what I'm going for is I'm trying to streamline what it is that I say.
And sometimes I don't have time for names.
It's sometimes I don't have time for feelings.
Okay?
But that doesn't mean that I'm not,
I'm not a fan of where wherever it is you do.
Okay.
And if you can't do the math on that,
then I really can't help you.
I mentioned earlier that I am a big fan of a fast and loud.
That's like my favorite fucking TV show.
Now that breaking bad is over.
I absolutely fucking love that show.
I love cars.
I love watching people that know how to fix him up.
But the funniest fucking thing ever is watching the dude,
Richard,
Richard Rawlings,
watching him bust these people down on cars is the funniest fucking shit.
I mean,
dude,
he beats the shit out of them.
I don't think I,
I don't remember laughing as much as I laugh when I watched that show.
He fucking destroys him.
He'll go out there,
right.
It's always the same shit.
Somebody got a thunder bird,
they got a corvette,
they got some mopar thing or whatever,
and he comes walking out.
He's always complimentary of the car when he wants it.
So he gets people excited,
like they got to make a sale.
They just don't realize how low much lower it's going to be.
So he always comes in and he goes,
wow,
man,
look at this high.
It's at 60,
68.
Yeah.
Wow.
Boths sits right body straight,
everything's cool,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
And that he always looks at him.
He just goes,
uh,
so,
what were you thinking?
And then the oldest is always like,
I mean,
I don't know.
I was thinking,
I was thinking like 30 and then Richard,
I don't give a fuck what they say.
He always just goes like,
ah,
man,
I can't do 30.
I can't,
I can't.
I come on,
I drove all the way out here.
I got to,
I got to tow it back.
I,
I can't,
I can't do 30 right.
So then the person who owns the car,
oh,
he says the same shit.
Well,
well what,
what uh,
you know,
come my way a little bit where,
what were you thinking?
And he's,
he always t his hands in his pocket and he acts like he's thinking about it,
which,
you know,
he is it.
He knew what the fuck he was offered.
The second he walked into the barn and he'll say like,
I was thinking like,
like 12
dude,
they go from 30 he takes him down to 12 so these guys like,
ah,
man,
I can't do 12 come on man,
I can't do that.
And then they,
they always come down quick and they go,
how about like 24 can you do 24 and then he comes back like,
man,
I could do like 13 and he's just inching up and that drop in like a fucking
elevator.
The Gut,
it's cables cut.
My favorite one I ever saw was he went in and potluck this 62 corvette off these
these people,
right?
And it was sitting in this fucking damp warehouse,
spooky looking,
fucking saw,
cutting of place.
And they buy the fucking thing.
The guy one of 30 grand for it,
any busted of down to 18 five so he brings the fucker,
think back,
I mean it's a corvette so he can't see any Russ cause it's a fiberglass body.
But when they look underneath it,
it's just rusted out to the point of like,
dude,
what?
Oh I don't,
why did we pick this car up?
But as luck would have it,
the guy who sold him the car there was,
it was actually his grandfather's car and there was people part of his family
tree that were like,
you shouldn't have sold that car.
That car was supposed to be for us.
So they go down to the gas monkey garage to buy this fucking car back.
All right,
so Richard site,
he hasn't to do it.
Hadn't had to do anything for it,
right.
He paid 18 five for it,
you know,
busted the guy down from 30 so the guy's own family members,
his nephew and his brother come in to buy the car back.
They tell him the whole fucking story.
And then Richard's like,
yeah,
cool man.
You can buy it back.
And they will like,
so what were you thinking?
And he goes,
you know,
I was thinking like 30
after bus and the guy from 30 down to 18 five he goes right back to that guy's
price.
So the cousin and the fucking uncle,
they're like,
hey,
stupid,
you bought the car from my brother.
We know what you've paid for it.
And the only time I've ever seen him get embarrassed,
he was like,
Oh,
I'm sorry man.
That's just what we do here.
He's like,
how about 22?
And he ended up selling it for fucking,
you know,
20 grand.
I don't know.
I probably just butchered all that.
But fast and loud,
you gotta check it out.
Uh,
I like it because they build cars that I feel like I could afford.
They don't have like that Meekum shit where everything's six figures.
I mean they,
they build like a bad ass car for like 25 30 grand after they paid like,
you know,
10 grand for it and redid everything.
I really liked that show.
So a shout out to anybody who lists who's on that show that listens to this
podcast.
I fucking love it.
Anyways,
what are we up to here?
What am I talking about?
What am I looking at here I am 31 minutes in.
Was there anything else I wanted to talk about?
How about the Patriots?
I watched that game on the flight that was unbelievable.
The last two touchdowns in that game where you couldn't find a better example of
a worst defense I've ever seen in my fucking life.
The Patriots had double coverage,
got to safety coming over the top,
our quarterbacks in position to swat down the ball and he swings at it like a
fucking change up and it goes right by him and the guy scores for fucking
touchdown.
Brutal.
And then what?
Brady threw an interception that we went down the field and the fucking saints
turn around and do the exact same thing in single coverage.
It was like neither team wanted to win the game,
but I want to chastise all those fucking patriots fans that left that fucking
left.
Like half the stadium looked like it left.
And I know a lot of people like girl boss,
Patriots fans sock.
It's like fuck you,
you'll fan suck to half of your fans suck.
That's what you have to understand about any,
any arena you go to.
The only reason why it is this,
it is the size that it is,
is it's because someday you're going to make a run at the title and they're
going to need all those extra seats.
All right?
But the reality is is when the team start shitting the bed,
half the people leave.
So those stadiums only need like patriots state and really only needs to hold
30,000 people.
You know,
if you had decided to agreement that I don't give a fuck if they're 14 and two
or two and 14 I'm coming to the Games.
You know,
I think it needs to be 30,000.
So,
uh,
I love that all those fuckers left and they have to go to work tomorrow and lie
and say that they were there.
Uh,
the red sox were great.
Most of the people stayed,
a couple,
two or three people I saw leave,
saw a couple of empty seats,
but everybody stayed.
It was just a great fucking weekend.
And I went to the Bruins game today I was actually walking over to the,
to the garden and I was just going to buy a hat and a all of a sudden hear guys
who needs tickets,
who these tickets.
And I knew they were playing the redwoods,
but I thought it was in Detroit.
And I said,
fuck it.
I'll go to the Goddamn game.
So I go into the game and like not going to drink,
drink a little water,
come back through the fucking podcast.
That what happens in between the fucking first and second period or second and
third period,
I run into an old drinking buddy of mine for back in the day,
the high school days pick up right where we left off.
Al Have One,
you know,
fucking three beers later.
Here we are.
So my apologies for being late and congratulations to the Redwings.
Uh,
it wasn't the greatest fucking games.
Matinee games usually suck.
You know,
there's usually an extra sorta like a mascot presence cause there's so many kids
there,
they usually don't fight,
you know,
which makes sense.
Right.
I want to ask you guys,
what was the last time he got into a fistfight at like two o'clock in the
afternoon?
It doesn't happen.
Fist fights happen at night.
I don't know why they just do it.
Feels right.
Um,
all right.
Is that it?
Is that all I have to talk about before I get into the letters?
Uh,
chief Seattle fast and loud.
Red Socks,
patriots Bruins.
Oh,
the half marathon,
which just make little notes here of Shit to talk about.
I was fucking walking through,
uh,
the Boston Commons walking through the pack and they were having this half
marathon and all it was was fucking ladies
and a fucking web look phenomenal.
They were crushing it,
right?
Run it down the street,
zero fucking body fat,
but still had booties on him.
I was loving every fucking second of it,
right?
Objectifying them as they tried to have a nice day of exercise.
So as I get closer to the finish line,
there's some woman on the mic and it's,
I dunno,
like she was just being so overly positive.
It was annoying the shit out of me.
She was announcing every woman that crossed the finish line.
I get announcing like the fucking top 10,
15,
20,
but the,
it took me like 20 minutes to walk through the park for one side to the other
side up by the State House and all I hear the whole time.
And uh,
you know,
Bertha Clifford from Attleboro,
he's just yelling everybody's Day.
Abigail twizzle Nixle from Marblehead.
Today is your day.
That's what she said about one of them.
Today is your day,
and I want to be like,
she fucking came in like 70th.
It's not her day.
It's not nearly a day.
She's fucking go home and look at some game film.
It's not her fucking day.
It's not a day by a long shot.
She's a coach.
She's fired the first third of that race,
bringing in an interim runner.
Today's your fucking day.
It's I,
it's just fucking ridiculous.
You know,
I get it.
Guys were in the world.
We're a bunch of dicks.
We don't give you a,
you're fucking dude.
So,
but I got to tell you,
there is a way of overcorrecting to the point where all you're doing is making
everybody this soft.
But I got to tell you,
those women weren't little races.
I'll tell you,
they probably didn't like that either.
They probably didn't like it either.
You know what I mean?
They're all fucking athletes.
Are you an athlete?
If you're a runner book,
he just put up with a lot of shit.
I'll tell you what I like about my girl,
man.
She's gotten dirt.
I came all been pitched about my job for four hours last night.
She never plate.
Uh Oh.
That was just one of those moments where I was just sitting there listening to
this fucking woman screaming out all these women's names.
Yeah.
You know Betty fucking,
whoever could gradual Laisha
I don't understand it.
You would think that all of them would sub regional fucking running thing and
now they were showing up hyping the race.
They would got to run rather than that person she just mentioned Cayman 47th oh
bill.
You know what?
The holidays are coming up.
Why don't you put a fucking red nose on and fucking take the cut down a little
bit.
All right.
You might be right.
Okay.
So anyways,
Kansas City is officially the loudest crowd
and at the end of the day,
nobody,
I think it's funny because I was trashing Seattle,
but nobody gives a fuck.
Okay.
Kansas City wants what Seattle wants,
wants what?
The patriots once,
once what everybody fucking,
once you are at the super bowl title,
that's what you will,
you'll be the loudest.
That's stupid.
The Seattle feds,
the fucking worst.
The way you guys so quickly came back to that older that fucked you over so bad.
Or the tall boy beers that were just as big as the small ones.
What is shape and he buys you back cause he fucking calls you 12th man waves of
fucking flag.
You know something Seattle.
I thought you were better than that.
Okay.
Did it hurts me to say that?
I guess I was wrong.
A lot of people that are actually gonna take that seriously.
Okay.
Followup to bully.
All right.
I guess this is one I,
if you can tell,
I've come,
I've been going down,
coming down with a little bit of a cold here.
That's what happens when you drink like 12 nights in a row,
you know,
it's not really the alcohol,
it's the out till four in the morning without a hat on.
A follow up to bully a day.
Billy red face.
This is a follow up to the email I sent about getting picked on all this was the
big dude,
right?
The big dude at school who could do something.
He's at the Dojo and all that type of shit.
But didn't want to do something cause he didn't want to disappoint his sensei.
If I'm using the right karate lingo and if I'm not,
I mean I,
I,
my apologies anyways,
he said it went a lot better than I expected.
Oh,
to give you a recap,
this guy was like a big guy and there was some fucking short fat kid that was
always coming up slapping him in the head at school or this guy seems like he's
studying at least two if not three different martial arts disciplines.
And if he wanted to,
okay.
Could,
you know,
do you know that shit that they do?
I don't even know what they do next.
So you know there that you feel the heat of their foot next year ear.
Yeah.
That you,
you know,
you wake up,
they were computer watching the youtube video,
whatever the fuck just happened to you.
He could basically do that.
But he didn't because he didn't want to discipline.
Disappoint his martial arts.
Teach teachers.
All right,
chase is bill.
All right.
Here we go.
He said it went a lot better than I expected.
I told one of my martial arts teachers any basically gave me a green light to
what?
This kid,
but not too bad.
No broken bones except maybe the nose.
Oh,
I love this guy.
This guy's old school.
Yeah.
He said,
I walked into the locker robe 80 greeted me with,
hey faggot.
Fuck.
Uh,
I replied with,
I hear your birthday's coming up.
What's Your Cup size?
He got pretty mad and said,
what'd you fucking say?
I said,
your cup size.
You Fat.
Fuck.
What is it?
I love it.
Did you see the fucking bitch?
And I'm coming out.
He said he walked at me and swung a haymaker.
I took it on the chin.
Jesus Christ,
you didn't slip.
He said I'd beat the shit out of this kid all let's go.
Cause he took a swing first.
Very nice.
Those,
I need them in the belly twice.
Once to the head.
I kicked him in the thigh.
Oh,
that's the one he's going to feel tomorrow.
that one's good.
That one's going to Bruce and he goes,
any went down?
I finished with a few punches to the head.
I got suspended for two days after they heard he was picking on me.
I think it's safe to say you won't be picking on anyone else anymore.
Have a great day and please say a fuck Kyle.
That's an inside joke with one of my friends are I do good for you,
good for you.
And you know something good for your teacher.
You know what I mean?
Can't always be holding people up at third base.
Every once in a while you got to wave of morale.
It comes,
that's route with the plank.
Right?
Good for you.
I was going to say,
I wish I could watch the video of it,
but you'd get in trouble for it.
So
by the way of drinking water that are doing sound is ice water and it's still
drinking on this thing.
All right,
here's a new topic that is,
is it hasn't come up,
which I wish you would come up more often.
A lesbian love.
Dear doctor Burr,
I have a bit of a girl dilemma here.
I'm a 26 year old dude living in Connecticut.
Uh,
Fuck Hartford.
Okay,
so you're living anywhere but Hartford or you're in Hartford.
You hate it.
He said,
I met a girl.
Oh,
wait a minute.
If this is coming from a guy,
all I see is threesome on the horizon.
All right,
please let this go the way I want it to go.
He said,
I met a girl through a friend of a friend and we became great friends.
She lives out of state,
but we still keep in touch and communicate with each other whenever we can.
All right.
You paint with a broad brush here.
That can be you text every once in a while or you're having,
fuck you're sexting or fucking,
you know,
pressing your Dick up against your computer while skyping.
I mean,
there's a lot of,
there's a,
you know,
there's a lot of room for interpretation there,
sir.
But I'll continue.
He says she's Independent.
Headstrong,
not materialistic.
Likes the same shit I do.
And we are always in sync whenever we get together.
Person to person,
basically.
Perfect for me.
And not to sound Corny,
at some point I fell in love with her though.
Don't ever apologize for falling in love with a woman.
That's just some guy shit where you can't pretend like you want to be happy too.
Good for you.
He said,
but she's a lesbian at any rides.
Oh,
Gigi Age.
Oh Wow.
Dude.
Did you know that going into it?
They voice cracking.
You didn't protect you fucking had,
um,
well you do with a chick thing when you think he can change her.
Uh,
all right.
He says it's a bit of an emotional struggle.
I would think so.
He said,
I've already shared my feelings and obviously they went nowhere.
So now you know,
I'm thinking now when you said she likes the same shit you like,
yeah,
I can see where you guys would be on the same page checking out the ladies.
It's anyways,
he goes to,
so now I've got a bottle that shit up inside.
It's been like that for almost a year.
Part of me still wants to be friends with her,
but the other parts of me tells me to forget about her and cut all
communications off.
Yeah,
I mean,
are you just keep looking at her going,
oh,
maybe she'll blow me today.
Ain't happening.
Uh,
he said,
I'd feel like a Douche.
Fuck,
you guys are really creating odd,
like a vulgarities here.
A douche.
Fuck.
Okay.
That's a new one.
If I cut all ties and yet I know it's going to suck for me.
Emotional,
as long as I'm friends with Tara because I'll never be with her or this feeling
go away.
Eventually my friends keep telling me to forget about her,
but I will always be losing an awesome,
but I would also be losing it.
Awesome.
Fred too.
What do you think,
Bill?
Should I listen to my heart?
I'm like cock.
Thanks.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Truly.
Uh,
let's see.
I would say a,
okay,
listen to your heart or your car.
I don't know which ones to do.
What your heart loves her.
And you also,
what a fucker.
Oh,
you have to do is you need to do a combo.
Like you have to have a sit down with both of your heart and your deck.
It just be like,
look,
all right,
your deck has to dull the score at this point.
It happening.
Okay.
You,
Dick probably already has its fucking helmet off.
It's taken as tape off and all that shit.
But your heart,
you know,
I don't know what you fucking are.
So listen to it.
I'm sorry I'm buzzed here.
Ah,
what do I think you should do a,
yeah,
I think you should.
You should just walk away.
You got to walk away and you got to be into some other chick first and then
maybe you can start to be friends again.
But,
uh,
yeah,
it sounds like you've been a sad puppy dog with blue balls for a year.
And I'd say you've,
uh,
I think you've done your pets.
You know,
why don't you go into the,
uh,
the open late?
Why don't you do that?
I just opened the register.
Could I,
can I have the next customer please go into that fucking line.
Yeah,
right.
Oh man,
that sucks.
I feel bad for you.
Do,
what are you going to do?
You know,
I saw the other day on the cover of Espn,
ESPN magazine,
they had one of those UFC chicks like totally naked,
but with their fucking goddamn hands wrapped.
And I gotta tell you something man.
I think those,
those women are hot.
They are fucking hot.
And I think it would make you a better person if you could date.
If you went out with a woman that could beat the shit out of you just because it
would fall,
it would,
it would force you to be smarter.
Where are reason why women are smarter than us is because basically speaking,
we can fucking stuff I'm going to hamper if we want to.
So they have to opt smartest.
So it's from day one they using their fucking braids.
We were just sitting there go and shut up,
you know,
using force.
There's not,
we're all fucking knees and elbows.
So what would happen is,
is you would gain the wisdom of a female by kind of being the bitch and the
relationship in that,
you know,
she could fucking slap you around.
Then you could learn to use tricks like guilt,
you know,
who knows,
maybe she'd go out and get you a pair of shoes.
Right?
I'm sorry.
So sorry that I put you in a Kamora.
Uh,
I've been meaning to that UFC show where they have the women in the house and
it's hard to watch women beaten the shit out of each other.
There's like no way that they could hit him,
hit each other,
that it's fucking pleasant to see.
Punched him in there.
Pretty faces or even worse where they take that fucking straight right to the
left tit.
It's just like,
what are you doing?
Okay.
You know,
I met Pete massage monistic here,
but I just look,
that's like for a baby.
Okay.
Why are they punching you and what are your fucking baby compartments?
Oh really?
I'm a moron.
I admitted,
you know,
whatever.
That's just how I look at it.
I'll tell you what,
at least I'm honest,
at least I'm honest.
That's when,
you know,
you said some ignorant shit and half the parties walking away from you.
Hey,
I,
hey.
You know,
I say what's on my mind.
I say what's up baby cell types?
You shouldn't.
All right,
here we go.
Ah,
okay.
I work at hell with no escape.
Hey,
Billy,
red beard,
the pirate.
I have a police officer in a town in New Jersey where I am at 11 year veteran.
All right.
How are you?
Good there dude.
You're over the hub.
What do you mean 20 years?
I said Cape bed.
Boles Hey,
you got to do that for another nine years.
Uh,
the department I worked for abuses those of us who have too much self respect to
kiss ass.
All right?
Not about trying to be a dick,
sir,
but you've already paid yourself as the hero here.
All right?
But I'm going to believe you,
okay?
Okay.
I'm going to believe that you actually do a good job.
And the reason why they don't like you is not because you're fucking,
uh,
be the cud.
It's because you don't kiss any ass.
All right?
I'm gonna go with that.
He said it's gotten so bad that they suspend and even try to fire guys who don't
bow down and kiss the ring.
It's the very definite definition of a hostile work environment and I'm terribly
stressed out about the situation.
Now you may be asking yourself is,
it's so bad.
Why don't you move on to another police department?
Thank you,
sir,
for giving me the credit for being that intelligent to have that thought.
Unfortunately,
I didn't,
I was immediately thinking that you should get together with somebody at Fred's
and become the surfer Akos out there.
You know,
it may be deep pants.
You're fucking a CPO,
whatever the fuck his neighbors,
you know,
start Hayes and him have a little mutiny.
Uh,
anyways,
he says,
well,
I've tried,
but the great,
the great fucked up state of New Jersey has a rule that says if I transferred to
another police department,
both of the department I work for and the department I want to go to have to
approve and sign off on the transfer.
I was this close to getting hired by another department.
It was denied the transfer of all my current police chief,
or as I called him Satan.
Apparently they could do that.
I hate stress,
but I have bad dreams about the place that it affects my mood.
When I think about it,
even when I'm off,
my question to you is,
if I have stuck,
you're the worst work imaginable.
How do I shake off the bullshit and not worry?
Thanks for all the laughs and I underestimated your ticket selling ability in
New Jersey.
I was a little late trying to get to a tickets to red bank.
Oh,
you know,
that's not that big a place,
sir.
Um,
but I appreciate the compliment.
Ah,
all right,
well here's the deal.
You can't have a let some Aila cut
affect your happiness,
happiness,
happiness.
All right.
It's all gonna come down to how you choose to react to what it is he's doing.
That's the first step.
All right.
Yeah.
They'll be idle.
This is a completely different scenario.
But I remember,
uh,
I used to live above this fucking angry old man and he used to always yell at me
every fucking thing I did,
my old apartment,
you know,
and I dropped his cell phone.
He keep it up to get all that shit and he yelled at me and all that shit.
So I,
um,
I just started hitting him with positivity,
you know,
me and Nia just started acting like he was attractive.
I just walked by and be like,
Hey,
what do you say to had good look it.
She'd whistle at him like he was sexy and it kind of brought up around in some
weird way and I don't know if you can do that.
Can you do that?
Can you fuck with your,
your superior officer like that when it comes in and he's a cut to you and just
just be,
hey guys,
sergeant,
you've been losing weight.
You're really fill it out.
That uniform quite nicely.
Just keep doing that uncomfortable shit to them.
And then,
uh,
I dunno if he's truly as bad as you say.
You can't tell me some of the other guys you work with don't feel the same
fucking thing.
I know you have the code of silence,
the Blue Code,
whatever the fuck it is,
you know.
But if somebody be that much of a deck,
it's subpar.
Might say it a rat the guy out.
Well maybe,
you know,
can you organize something or is everybody's too nervous that they won't get
another stripe on their fucking costume?
Is that what it is?
I don't fucking know.
Sorry.
You know what is,
I can just tell you,
I feel for you.
I don't know what to tell you.
You're talking about cops here.
He's got a God damn gun.
MMM.
How would you start sending them flowers and chocolates?
It like this positive way.
Just annoy the shit out of him.
You know,
I leave a little love letters on his car.
You don't need to sign it.
I would just start fucking with them just to give yourself something that is,
he's be to cut to you.
You know that he's going to go out there and read,
you know,
his secret male admirer,
love letter.
Just something.
Something to fuck with the guy.
What else could you do?
Ah,
there's the usual shit.
Laxatives
I would do,
I don't know what I would do.
I would say like the Mary Tyler Moore Song to him every time he was a,
to me who can turn the world od with his smile.
Well it's you sergeant.
You should know it with each little county.
Fucking move your show it.
Why are you such a deck?
It's just fucking,
this is a great thing about humor.
If it's funny,
it's fine.
You just got to make sure you get a laugh.
And other than that,
I would,
uh,
you know,
dude,
you got another nine years.
You can't let somebody take a decade from here.
So I would,
I would do whatever it is I had to do,
you know,
grab some beers with some of the other guys.
You probably can't trust them.
There's always some kiss ass.
It's going to fucking rat you out.
I don't want to ruin your career here.
Jesus do it.
I don't know what to tell you.
I would just,
I mean,
other than the fucking singing songs to him,
okay,
yeah.
Cubs entities telling you some shit you don't want to do.
Just look right at him and dead.
Serious abuse for like God,
you've got beautiful eyes.
Just something like that.
Just keep fucking with them.
Cause that's a way whether you can still carry out whatever country order he
told you to do,
but you still hold onto a piece of yourself.
That's the best I have for you.
Other than that,
I would explore some sort of organized way.
Okay.
To fucking tip this guy over in his squad car.
I all by helped you out sir,
because that uh,
I got miserable reading that.
Okay.
All right.
Where the fuck out for 55 minutes and have I done it?
I think it's time for some more advertising here.
Everybody.
Uh,
here we go.
He voiced ie voice.
If you're an entrepreneur and a customer calls,
do you want him to see?
Do you want to seem like you're in a high rise window view?
Fancy pants office.
Oh,
do you want them to know you're just sitting there and your underwear drinking?
Hi C.
Huh?
It's a no brainer with the voice.
You can create the appearance of an entire building.
Sales,
customer support,
tech support,
you name it.
Everybody will think you got it.
Give your customers the royal treatment with the voice.
He voice will forge your business calls to your whole mobile already.
You choose wherever you are.
He voice,
we'll find you.
Don't have time to take a call,
no biggie.
It's routed to your voicemail and you can read it at your convenience as an
email.
He voice not only gives you an edge over your competitors,
it takes away the edge the big companies have over you right now.
It's immediately a level playing field.
Thank God for a voice.
You could try it right now for free for 30 days.
Go to [inaudible] dot com or just go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com
it.
Click on the voice banner,
and last but certainly not least,
yeah,
hitting cleanup,
legal zoo of everybody,
a lot of pride cubs along with starting your dream business.
But think about the stress you'll feel if you don't take the right steps to
legally protect business and
personal assets from the beginning.
That's why I yours truly recommend legal zoom.com during the past 12 years,
over a million business owners have trusted legal zoom to help start their
businesses.
Legal Zoom will save you a lot of time and a pile of money on startup costs.
Plus they'll provide solutions to help you run a successful business.
Legal Zoom can help provide self help services at your specific direction or
connect you with an attorney,
but they are not.
Repeat,
not a law firm.
Just go to legalzoom.com today and see what's right for you.
Form an LLC,
get a Dba,
incorporate or form and profit all starting at just 99 bucks.
Plus you'll save even more when you enter my last day.
Berbee you are are in the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com promo code [inaudible] one more time.
legalzoom.com Promo Code Bar.
Oh,
I lied.
There's one more and I get there.
Hang in there.
All right,
so you don't have to start your business.
You're not to watch TV.
United Shave.
You know how to protect your business.
What's the last thing you need to know how to do?
You need to not to go to the post office in 2013 stamps.com everyone.
There are over 8 million small businesses out there.
Many of them are wasting time going to the post office for their mailing and
shipping.
What they don't know.
There's a much better way.
What is it?
stamps.com stamps.com brings all the services of the post office right to your
fingertips.
Use Your own computer and printer to get official US postage for any legal,
for any letter or package stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale.
Automatically calculates the exact postage for any class of bail.
It's so easy to use and convenient.
Even a moron like me has been able to do it.
You'll never waste time again.
Going to the post office,
you won't even need to lease one of those expensive postage meters.
I use stamps.com to set out all my DVDs,
my tee shirts,
whatever crap you see me whored myself out with at the end of my shows,
stamps.com got it there.
Never had a problem.
Right now,
use my last name burpee.
You are for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale it up to $55
free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the whole page and type in Bar B u r r
that stamps,
stamps.com enter burr a right.
That'll be enough of that close in that window.
And then we're back to the podcast with the next.
Done a provocative word,
crazy blowjob
rollout.
Those lazy,
crazy hazy fucking blow jobs.
But Beta [inaudible] Beta the boot,
but up up beep had bell last night.
I got laid while breaking bad was playing in the background from my computer.
Okay,
well thank Vince Gilligan.
And then Amy,
uh,
now I had a little trouble keeping the guy up during the act,
even though she had the ass I would kill for to see again.
So while she was giving me head,
which was awesome by the way,
I look up,
what do I see or the TV,
Billy,
the freckled face card shows up in a truck.
This is a true story,
by the way.
I remember that.
That's when we shot that one at us.
Santa Fe.
We shot that one to Santa Fe when we robbed the a rob the train.
I'm not gonna say anything else cause everybody,
let's just start at the theories.
Uh,
yeah.
How am I say I couldn't decide between keep watching the scene because I had the
seed.
You acting before or joining the blowjob.
Well,
dude,
have you ever heard of hitting pause
this guy?
He's like,
fuck it.
He's,
he loves,
I thought,
I love breaking bad.
This guy loves it.
He says the whole situation was really awkward because I was imagining you
saying stuff like,
dude,
why are you watching TV while getting a blow job?
What do you have egg?
Uh,
he goes,
I actually started laughing,
not thinking about how uncomfortable that would make her the poor girl.
Oh No.
I was struggling to keep it up while hearing you in my head going,
this guy's a fig.
Uh,
that's my joke.
Making fun of people who will homophobic.
By the way,
just to clarify it before I have to apologize to an overweight blogger on
television.
Uh,
the remote control was not in my reach,
so I had to watch the camera all today between two redheaded con
Heisenberg and old Billy red face
Heisenberg's in a red ready and a shaved it.
You're talking about Jesse Plemons.
I don't fucking know.
He said.
Anyways,
thanks for ruining a great blow job.
You can't,
I'll see you in Sweden in December.
Uh,
hey,
my apology sir.
But you guys,
you know,
okay.
I know that you're,
you're way over there in Sweden,
but I would think that you,
that you guys have remote.
You,
I know you have remote controls and you have pause buttons.
I've been there.
You know,
that's really weird,
sir.
That made me uncomfortable with myself getting a blowjob in Sweden.
Jesus Christ.
It was probably some chick that'd be a fucking 11 over here until you guys is
just another,
uh,
just another chick from fucking Stockholm.
Right.
Um,
I always mentioned that whenever I go over there,
when you're in Stockholm,
the city of Stockholm,
it's just,
it's fucking ridiculous.
Uh,
not saying there aren't some regular looking people,
but just the percentage of really good looking people is,
uh,
you know,
I,
I'm a little,
I felt like a mongoloid when it was over there.
Like I really need to,
like,
I had,
should have like a hump limping down the fucking street.
Um,
so anyways,
do check it off and uh,
I hope that girl didn't hear you laugh and while she was blowing you,
cause that could really affect her confidence.
So make sure you,
she knows why you will laugh at all.
Right.
And just say,
hey,
we're not going to watch TV this time.
And then she'll go to blow you again,
and then just the sheer quietness in the room is going to make you start
thinking about my dumb face again.
You're going to laugh again.
You have an issue,
sir.
Uh,
all right.
The Opera Decker,
dear Saint Bill,
I'll get to the point asap.
My boss' book,
me a hotel without a fridge.
What I go to got to the hotel.
They told me their computers showed up,
showed that the fridge fridges rubs had not been cleaned.
I ask,
could you just bump me up to one with the fridge?
Then they responded with the polite no.
They then sent a guy to check if any other those rubs were clean.
The fridge hustle fridges rooms.
Uh,
they told me one of them was,
which I figured means it had been cleaned.
I took the room.
I had four strong beers,
dog fish,
head,
90 minute IPA.
I don't know what that means.
I know IPA is have more alcohol,
but I don't know what 90 minute means.
He said that it anyways,
he says that I went to take a shower.
I noticed that there was no soap,
which means no one
fix the room.
That dude who checked must have just made the bed to top it off.
The toilet is not working.
Shit would notch flush.
So
I took an opera decker inside the top part of the toilet.
My question is,
am I an asshole?
P s this happened 20 minutes ago.
Still drunk.
Love you work.
Are you an asshole?
Absolutely.
You are an asshole because the person who manages that hotel is not the person
who has to clean out the toilet.
And uh,
oh,
you gotta do is just fuck over the person who's got to clean it up.
Yeah.
He should've done that shit.
Come on,
man.
Come on.
Yeah.
The mature thing to do is you pick up the phone and you say,
yeah,
I was said that this rule was ready.
It's not ready.
There's no soap in here.
This hasn't been,
basically the bed has been made.
The toilet's not working.
That's what you do.
Okay.
You know,
you don't take a shit the top part of the fucking toilet.
All right.
Shayla,
you have disappointed in you.
You know better than that.
I'll give you a little bit of a slap suit.
Four beers in.
You already did that.
Thank God you didn't have eight.
You know,
he probably would have shit in the hall.
Uh,
wrap up.
Okay.
That's it.
People.
That's the podcast here.
Okay.
That's the head.
See I did all right.
I did it right.
You got cell phone six hours,
five that it's,
yeah,
that's a decent size podcast.
All was adorable little podcast.
Listen,
now that the show's over,
don't forget to sign up for your free trial of Hulu.
Plus Hulu plus lets you binge on thousands of hit shows.
Anything anytime,
anywhere on your TV,
PC,
spot,
phone or tablet support.
This podcast,
get an extended free trial of Hulu.
Plus when you go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot com they click the Hulu
plus batter or go to Hulu plus.club/bill.
That's Hulu plus.com/.
Bill a real quick,
my next big gigs coming up is a,
what is it?
November 7th,
eighth and ninth,
three of the biggest gigs I've had up until this day.
Uh,
I'm going to be at Constitution Hall in Washington DC.
I've got to be,
uh,
the beacon theater in York City and that I've got to be an upper Darby,
Pennsylvania.
Those dates are November 7th,
eighth and ninth.
And as always,
I'm going to have the lovely Paul Versey opening for me.
Uh,
that's a Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
Um,
most of those,
the first show was sold out.
I think that's just one show in DC,
but there's two in New York and two in,
uh,
Phillipe.
So the first shows I believe are both sold out and the second one is going fast.
So once again,
thank you to everybody who,
uh,
has bought up the tickets and uh,
I'm coming with the best hour that I've written.
That's what I like to think.
And the weekend after that,
I'll be in deadwood,
South Dakota.
The Billy red state make updates.
The last three deadwood,
South Dakota on the 15th.
Tulsa,
Oklahoma at Brady theater,
Tom Brady,
uh,
November 16th,
and the Orpheum theater,
Wichita,
Kansas,
November 17th.
Oh,
really quickly,
by the way,
the Broncos one again,
I got to tell you,
he's all,
I'm seeing a flaw in that team is great as they look Bronco fans,
I want to hear from you.
I'm not being a dick,
but they're looking like that classic regular season team that scores a zillion
points.
But let's up half a zillion.
And I found that those teams tend to lose in the playoffs.
Playoffs,
the San Diego,
the air corps,
yell chargers,
the Dan Marino dolphins,
the fucking greatest show on turf rams the year we beat them,
the year the giants beat the fucking undefeated patriots.
Um,
that shit catches up with you because when you go to the playoffs,
you're going to be playing teams with great defense.
And when they slice your offense and half,
but your defense can't step it up,
all of a sudden you got a close game.
And next thing you know,
you lose 20 to 17.
You like,
what the fuck happened?
We scored 9 million points to season.
All right,
Ben there as a fan,
what do you think we're taking filed calls right now?
Uh,
that's it.
That's a podcast for this week.
I'll fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.